There's this former Republican congressman
named, uh, Joe Wolf.
He's really a disgusting guy, much like Steve
King, Big Tea Party guy is Joe Walsh.
When he was in Congress, used to have a radio
show where he would say horribly inflammatory
things.
He is now apologizing, apologizing for his
role in helping to get Donald Trump elected
in 2016 he wrote a New York Times op ed yesterday
where he said, quote and Mr. Trump, I see
the worst and ugliest iteration of views I
expressed for the better part of a decade
to be sure I've had my share of controversy
on more than one occasion.
I questioned Mr Obama's truthfulness about
his religion.
At times I expressed hate for my political
opponents.
We now see where this can lead.
There's no place in our politics for personal
attacks like that, and I regret making them
so okay.
I mean, this is good.
Walsh is realizing how destructive and terrible
Trump has been.
He's realizing how destructive and terrible
some of the things he did, which are similar
to the personal type attacks that Donald Trump
makes.
Uh, how terrible those were.
But he didn't just help elect Donald Trump.
This guy's entire moral compass is completely
backwards.
He wants tweeted, if Trump loses, I'm grabbing
my musket.
That's not a personal attack.
That's actually a threat of violence, a specific
threat of violence from a prominent Republican.
He said on Twitter, a quote, I'll just say
it, Sandy Hook parents.
Your 15 minutes is up against, I guess, gun
safety activists coming out of the sandy hook
shooting.
And who even knows what he meant by that.
I could give you a really long list, but the
point is this guy wasn't just a supporter
of Trump in 2016 and he regrets supporting
Trump because Trump has been bad or something
like that.
He was supporting Trump in the most toxic
and destructive way possible while simultaneously
being a completely deplorable right wingers.
So, okay, it's good that he changed his mind
about Trump.
His point, I guess, is to encourage a primary
challenge against Trump.
He tweeted yesterday, quote, why did I write
this piece?
Two reasons.
First, I wanted to make clear that Donald
Trump is unfit to be president and he must
be challenged in the Republican primary.
And second, I wanted to apologize for the
role I played in helping to put an unfit man
in the White House.
So I, I've said before, it's a problem in
our society when people become irredeemable.
And we've actually, when we talked to former
extremists last week, I interviewed former
Neo Nazi, frank mink.
He said one of the things that helps get extremists
out of their views is becoming redeemable,
being redeemable, and being re accepted by
society when they attempt to write the wrongs
and move out of their horrible extremist ideology.
That lack of empathy is what often gets extremists
into extreme views in the first place.
And so it's really important that people don't
become irredeemable to society.
And I agree with that, right?
I mean, we, we need people to be redeemable
in order to encourage more people to reconsider
their actions.
At the same time, he still a toxic republican
who doesn't like Trump and who was so ignorant
or blinded by partisanship to a degree that
I guess he didn't realize the extent of the
damage that he was doing by supporting Donald
Trump.
Good for him.
I mean, it's tough to own up to mistakes.
If more people did, it would be better off
as a society.
But this doesn't change that Joe Walsh still
would put elected officials in power who want
terrible policy and who, if they are allowed
to do what it is they want to do, would be
hugely destructive in terms of the direction
of the country.
If it were up to Joe Walsh, we would have
what?
A slightly less insane, less toxic republican
as president.
That's not what the left is looking for.
Beyond the one point of agreement that Trump
has to go.
So let's give him credit where he deserves
credit.
It's tough to say, I made a mistake.
It's tough to do it publicly.
That's great.
At the same time, let's not pretend like now
this guy is an ally of some kind whose political
views aligned with ours.
There's also another angle here.
The idea being Republicans are simply realizing
that Trump is a losing ticket.
So it's not that they're abandoning Trump
because they don't like Trump's style, tone,
tenor, or way of doing business.
They're trying to get themselves off of a
sinking ship before it takes them down.
So they're claiming that it's moral grounds
that have them objecting to Donald Trump.
But really it's a lot of them think Trump
will lose, in which case this is actually
even less genuine than we believe it to be.
Let me know what you think.
I'm glad giving credit where credit is due.
We just don't want to give more credit than
what is actually do